Kim Kardashian is being dragged for her
latest clap back Rihanna is embracing
her curves in British Vogue plus the
inspiring 71 year old dancer on a GT
last night well it looks like Kim K
slipped up twice this weekend it's only
Wednesday hey guys this is the daily
Denny I'm Denny direct Oh Kim is being
blasted over her new slimmer body and
one clap act that has only made it worse
it all started with this photo the
reality star was snapped Monday before
she hit Jimmy Kimmel Live and the pic
was posted on Instagram and that's when
model Tyson Beckford chimed in with this
body shaming comment quote sorry I don't
care for it personally and she is not
real doctor blinked up on her right hip
all right time out let's not forget when
Kim had her butt x-rayed on Keeping Up
with the Kardashians to prove she didn't
get implants okay Tyson
well Kim quickly slapped back to herself
writing sis
we all know why you don't care for it
ooh now this is a bit problematic some
are calling her response homophobic and
Kim I get it you want to fight back at
people who clean you get plastic surgery
I bet you worked real hard for that body
but you missed the mark
don't fight fire with fire folks because
Tyson then responded he said my opinion
on women who do plastic surgery stays
the same not for me
always gonna pick a Beyonce over anyone
else okay well don't bring B into this
right now this is hardly the first time
Kim the 37 year old has hit back at her
critics after Chloe grace Moretz and
Bette Midler commented
unenthusiastically on Kim's nude selfie
Kim wasted no time calling them out on
Twitter and of course you can forget Kim
and Taylor Swift viewed when she
released video of a phone call allegedly
between Kanye and Taylor on snapchat but
now the reality star is facing some
serious backlash for some recent
Instagram stories that some followers
say glorify eating disorders wait what
was that Kendall
what thank you
what was that you said okay sorry
continue continue what yeah that didn't
sit well with a lot of people including
actresses Emmy Rossum and Brooklyn
nine-nine Stefanie Beatrice who both
reminded their followers the danger of
praising things like anorexia and they
offered their support for those
struggling with their body image and I
agree Kim if you worked hard for your
body good on you but like let's see more
of your favorite workouts how you
maintain your diet when your kids are
running around eating chicken nuggets
let's keep it positive people not
triggering just by I mean look at
Rihanna bad girl RiRi is keeping it real
as she always does about body image with
British Vogue which by the way Rihanna
is the first black woman to grace the
cover of their September issue might be
she slays but it's inside the mag where
the Barbados Beauty had the best
response when asked why she thinks she's
the woman other women love she says
maybe it's because she's thick now
that's th I see see aka those sexy
curves and RiRi even confesses to
British Vogue I'm about to get back into
the gym and I hope I don't lose my butt
on my hips or all of my thighs I'll lose
some but not all and I think if my boobs
like I'm gonna lose everything
everything goes but you know it comes
with the price you want to have a but
then you have a gut
look Ria's proof you can be sexy at any
size and she has schooled et firsthand
on that matter
part of my plan preach girl
now while Rihanna is inspiring women
they can be sexy at any size last
night's golden buzzer on America's Got
Talent is showing everyone you can chase
your dreams at any age now we've seen a
lot of dancers come and go on a GT but
perhaps none as inspiring as Quinn and
Misha take a look I want to show the
world
hey listen just because just 60-70 don't
sit there before time world champions
include a 71 year old twin moved guest
judge Martina McBride with her story and
her talent you inspired everybody of all
ages and then this happened
[Music]
when Anisha are going straight to the
live shows
that message is something that so many
people can benefit from here now you see
y'all it's never too late to do what you
want where would you want and be what
you want okay you can write that down
all right send me off my soapbox but I
love you come back tomorrow for more
daily to